I think he has eroded a norm In America
which is that we that there is a
touchstone the truth is real there is a
touchstone that is the truth and we
measure our leaders by their tether to
that Touchstone you know when Barack
Obama said something about health
insurance it was inaccurate he was held
accountable he had to explain the danger
I saw in Trump and still see is that the
lies are so
so extensive that they could wash away
the Touchstone and we would stop judging
without even realizing it but drop the
norm that it matters whether our leaders
tell the truth or not and so he did that
by beating down the Press by constantly
constantly reinforcing the
preconceptions of the members of his
political cult and it's a it's a long
walk back from a place where we've lost
that at the center of American life then
on top of that closer to my work is he's
intentionally taken a flamethrower to
the Department of Justice and the FBI
for reasons that I understand if you
think about his world view he knew if a
threat was going to come to him that's
where it would come and so he would prep
that Battlefield by burning it down long
in advance and now he's pulling on those
reserves among his supporters I told you
they were corrupt I told you they were
evil and that's a dangerous place to be
because you can criticize it should
criticize government institutions but
we need to see those Justice
institutions as separate from the
political and he's made sure I mean even
to say this if you put this in a script
to be rejected the notion that the FBI
is a bunch of
leftists bent on destroying Republicans
in the United States is so crazy that
just to say it out loud seems silly but
there are millions of Americans who
believe that because it's been repeated
over and over and over again so among if
I could go on with the depressing list
but that's probably enough right now
what's what's your what's your biggest
worry if there was a second Trump
president saying what what more damage
could he do
he
I'm loathed to be too prescriptive
because I can see ways that he could do
more damage also you don't want to give
him ideas correct
correct I think the danger maybe I'll
just say it in this way
I think he understands better how things
work
and his Supporting Cast would be even
deeper towards the bottom of the barrel
than the last time and so he would be
the retribution president with a better
understanding of the levers of power
surrounded by a group of people who are
looking to burn it all down and our
system would survive that but he could
do things that would be much more
lasting damage they did the last time
the worrying thing that I'm reading is
that his Camp campaign team are actually
much more
focused and much more effective and
efficient than the rather kind of ragbag
team that he had in 2016 because I think
they signed up think it would be a jolly
Adventure yeah and we're not going to
win but it'll be a laugh whereas this
lot now that he has he's cleared out
either he's cleared out or his family
have cleared themselves out but there's
no sign of Ivanka and all although it's
it's very very hard-nosed thorough
highly professional campaigners and and
that's that's the one I think you I mean
you mentioned a cult the Republican and
you had you were previously registered
as as a republican voter you you've been
a republican voter yeah correct so how
do you feel about the Republican party
because you know they're not they're not
doing much to stop this we've had
Republicans there was a Republican
representative who talked about how the
the FBI should be defunded and
dismantled you know defunding the police
was the it was the criticism was the
Mantra that the right used against the
left
four or five years ago as as something
that the you know the uh the extremists
left we're talking about but here's a
republican yeah talking about
dismantling defunding yeah I don't think
the Republican Party exists anymore in
the United States and and some sign of
that is the last time there was a
Republican presidential campaign they
didn't have a platform but they don't
stand for anything that's why I wasn't
being again trying to be wise and
calling it occult it is a cult of
personality and it's just about
hating and grievance and it's centered
on this person and so it's hard to even
recognize it now there's still
Republican office holders and most of
them want to keep their office enough
that they will say or do anything to
placate the base because the base could
deprive of their office by voting
against them in a primary election and
so there's a there's a cynical deeply
cynical crust at the top and then a
whole lot of people who've been
harvested by a demagogue this was the
great fear of the founders in America
and we're seeing a once not just in a
lifetime once in many lifetimes
demagogue and he will not succeed but it
sounds contradictory but
to assure you he's not going to succeed
in being elected president but only if
the American people participate the way
they did last time and to recognize the
danger they face CNN got a lot of
criticism for its Town Hall in the
states and I at a difference they did
that town hall with with Trump did that
the idea was you gave him a platform and
my view is
no I like that because I want the
American people to see you cannot take
this election off and think well we
fixed that because the threat is in some
ways more severe but what where did you
know Republicans
uh normal I'm going to call you normal
Republican normal Republicans like you
who I think have a clear sense of uh
it's everything in your whole career
which I'll go to in a second sense of
public duty
um the importance of uh serving the
community
um there's a whole sense of Republican
family values that clearly aren't
manifested in Donald Trump so where do
they go if you as you say the real
Republican party has has disappeared
Well for now all thoughtful principled
Republicans need to go and most have
gone
to address the threat I mean I
campaigned for Joe Biden and they should
do so again because this is above any
policy disagreements I mean we have
robust disagreements in America but as
you do here about all kinds of policy
issues okay great that's what a
democracy should be about but above
those disagreements are things that are
common ground the rule of law for
example and so the voting and the
activism has to be aimed at that and
we'll get back to important
disagreements about taxation or
regulation but those things pale in
comparison to the threat to the thing
above and are you worried that you know
Biden is even older than Trump he he's
beginning to look frailer now
do you think people will come out for
Biden
I do as they did last time because
sort of a backhanded compliment but he's
a lot better than the alternative and so
I think people will come out and say
well I wish he was younger I wish it was
Kamala Harris I wish it was Pete
butterjudge or somebody fine
but he's the candidate and so what
you're always choosing I forget who said
don't oh Joe Biden says don't choose
between me and the almighty choose
between me and the alternative and so
given who the alternative is likely to
be
it's really important that people
recognize that's the choice and engage
on it don't take this one off and I
again Lincoln was fond of quoting his
secretary of state during the Civil War
who said there's always enough virtue in
America to save her and then he paused
and said but just enough
and that was a description of our
country in
1863. it's still a fair description of
America we'll be okay because it's
enough virtue but there isn't a surplus
of virtue that allows people to take an
election off